and of course you named uh the projects
the rockets that blue origin is working
on after some of the folks involved I
don't understand why I didn't say new
gagaran I is that there's an American
bias in the naming I apologize very
strange just asking for a friend clarify
I'm a big fan of garens though and fact
I um I think his his first words in
space um I think are incredible he you
know he Ed ly said my God it's blue and
that really drives home no one had seen
the Earth from space no one knew that we
were on this blue planet yeah no one
knew what it looked like from out there
and gagaran was the first person to see
it one of the things I think about is
how
dangerous those early days were for
gagaran for for Glenn for everybody
involved like how how big of a risk they
were all taking they were taking huge
risks I'm not sure what the uh Soviets
thought about about gagarin's flight but
I think that the Americans thought that
the Allen Shepard flight the flight that
you know new Shephard is named after the
first American in space he went on his
suborbital flight they thought he had
about a 75% chance of success um so you
know that's a pretty big risk a 25% risk
it's it's kind of interesting that Alan
Shepard is not quite as famous as John
Glenn so for people don't know Alan
Shepard is the first uh astronaut the
first American in space American in
suborbital Flight correct and and then
the first orbital flight is then John
Glenn is the first American to orbit the
Earth by the way I have the most
Charming sweet incredible letter from
John Glenn which I have framed and hang
on my office wall what do he say where
he tells me how uh grateful he is that
we have named new Glenn after him and
they sent me that letter about a week
before he died um and it's really an
incredible it's also a very funny letter
he's he's writing and he says you know
this is a letter about new Glenn from
the original Glenn and he's just he's
got a great sense of humor and he's very
he's very um happy about it and grateful
it's very sweet does he say PS don't
mess this up or is
that no he doesn't make me look good he
doesn't do that but wait but John
wherever you are we got you
covered
that